so the lemur can fly what was that a
fake I totally missed that like there's
a scene where they like the lemur grabs
the scroll and he just he grows wings
and flies out like what did they
introduce that that's really threw me
for a loop so uh yes sorry if I missed
that part uh that was one of the big
things that stood out but not the
biggest thing uh that this episode is
the the waterbending scroll
and I hate to sound like a broken record
but yeah it's just it's another really
good episode um what I'm liking about
the ones that affiliate a lot of action
it and good action as well is that the
climax of these they solidly build they
have good pacing so that we get to the
end you feel like this is a big climax
they're almost like movie climaxes and I
think to sort of work in all this
character and in this continuing story
and good action and even some morals and
legitimate climax at the end in under 24
minutes as really impressive um this
episode you got um they come across the
this village where they're there angers
trying to learn how to waterbend
and Katara knows a bit about tries
teaching him totally upstages her you
know he's very humble about she starts
to get a little angry
um and they find this water scroll that
she steals from some pirates which is
sort of a half lesson and this is it
okay to steal from someone that already
stole it uh my thought is they're going
to the North Pole anyway so she returns
it it now be redeemed in my opinion um
so uh so they get those water scroll and
the Fire Nation uh in a sense follows
them kind of by accidents or noticing
this like they're following them almost
by accident
um and the the uncle wants to change
course because he's missing this piece
like a game piece or something like that
uh and he alters the whole course to go
and get this one game piece and I I
don't know about that unless the game
piece plays a bigger role later I'm not
like I know the idea
behind the uncle the uncles very funny
in this one by the way um I know the
idea behind him is that you know that
the prince is very wound up very angry
and very anxious and is so focused on
the prize that he forgets he needs to
relax he needs to breathe and that that
balances out because we get stressed and
angry you get stupid
um but altering a whole course just for
this this one game fees and I mean edit
being in his sleeve in the end that
that's great um you know it's just about
everything with the humor and the uncle
and this is great but I thought that was
kind of odd like even for him to alter
the whole course to go after it even if
it did lead to finding the avatar unless
he has some sort of sense that they're
not going into yet I'm yes are the fun
of the show is that's like you don't
know yet you don't know this stuff's
gonna come in but for now that was a
little weird but of course they come
across the kid and you know high jinks
ensue um I I guess another thing about
this episode I know it's weird to go on
on about stuff that didn't happen and to
like the fact that didn't happen but
when you realize how often it does
happen in other shows in our movies it's
very much appreciated and that's when uh
guitars getting really angry that Aang
is so good at waterbending she actually
snaps at him really fast
he's being nothing but kind I mean he
say oh I have such a great teacher
that's why I'm doing so good and she
snaps at him and yeah gee I mean again
being younger he gets like the quibble
lip like really I'm sorry Lee and she
immediately backtracks which I really
like again it's like okay here's gonna
be the episode it's gonna be her
becoming too obsessed and she has to
find out how she was wrong and so and
she gets it right away for the most part
I like the fact that she does sort of
take it later and wants to keep learning
from it and I they capture the
frustration for trying to learn it very
well too because if anyone tried to pick
up a new skill I mean you know how
frustrating it is to try something a
person to just keep failing and failing
and failing and that even though
technically you're getting better but in
your mind you're still failing in
killing and failing I thought they'd
show that pretty well they capture her
frustration really well um so and at the
very end they're like what did I learn
that stealing is bad unless it's from
Pirates ha ha ha I'm like you know what
specifically were we trying to learn
here because it's like they come
together at the end to uh you know
bend the water and get the ship out and
they also help out uh you know and they
work together you know as not just are
being angry obviously um but again it's
like no no the lesson was about stealing
I think so
Oh may that's kind of a charm - it's
like it doesn't have to necessarily be
hammered in but it was a touch confused
on this but it may be us just for a fun
joke at the end um what else what else I
like that things like he buys this
whistle that just looks like a little
whistle that doesn't work um but it
actually brings it calls to the flying
bison I am assuming because the first
time he blows that the flying bison
doesn't come I only comes the second
time so yeah that's my assumption though
there might be I wasn't missing
something again but in Depok nitpick um
we have pirates in this episode this
time till we got like up what the hell
was that like a parrot with hands or
something that's spying again cool
designs um and uh you know I've been
there cute maybe could even used a
little bit more of them I like the
haggling between began the comedy this
one was really good
as I mentioned before particularly with
the uncle there's one point where you
know uh Katara says this is all my fault
and Aang's like no no it isn't and
uncle's like yeah actually it is some
really good humor I loved him finding
the piece in the sleeve and I loved it
being thrown over and hitting the other
pirate on the head I mean little little
touches like that are wonderful and the
last thing I'll say about those I was
talking about the action before um and
maybe this is because I don't watch kid
shows nowadays so maybe this is like a
common thing I don't know but when I was
growing up even with the really great uh
you know well-written AG
shows you know like x-men and Batman
stuff like that uh the action was very
basic like every once a while to be like
maybe two or three really cool moves in
an action cartoon and then the rest of
us are the basic punch duck uppercut you
know kick massive jump that nobody could
do you know so those are the basic and
then there'd be like two or three really
cool moves that you know if you go Wow
awesome
Batman's awesome uh this show me these
fight moves are very much like they're
well choreographed it's almost like they
have a different division just focusing
on what the fight moves are gonna be
because they're so well planned out and
we've seen that other forms of animation
like a lot of anime but again because
they take so much time usually you'll
have some sort of anime show where it's
like the focus will mainly be on the
action and the rest is really stilted
really still and the story might be flat
or something it's very rare or you get
that thing to where you get two or three
really cool moves and then the rest are
kind of basic it's very rare that you
get such a good balance like this and
that is why I'm seeing more and more as
how well this show is balanced you know
even the humor which at first I was
serving about it it seems to be getting
strong and stronger to a point where
it's like I'm laughing hard at a lot of
these jokes like it's not like oh hey
that's funny bye kid show Stander's no
this is like legitimately funny um so
yeah again I just love I love the
balance in the show I love how there's
so much attention to detail and and all
these things and even one last thing the
prince
when the uncle says he changed the
course just to go after this piece I
still like the fact the prince will
still do it he could whatever say no
screw that order let's go this way he
still has enough trust in his uncle even
though he doesn't always get what he's
talking about what he's doing that he
will still allow it um so so I really
like that he even though it builds that
frustration there is that trust between
those two and I think that's really
really good
so yeah again broken record but it's
just another really good episode
great action great comedy get still good
stuff with the characters great
animation all that good stuff so they
just they keep getting better and better
and uh just see you at number 10